welcome back we're now starting section
8 on page 547
okay and i think we're in the third test
so problem number one
if e is the set of even numbers
even integers sorry e is a set of even
integers p is a set of positive integers
and f is the set of integers less than
five which of the following integers
will be
in all three sets so we're looking for
something that meets all the constraints
so it has to be even
it has to be positive
positive
and it has to be less than five okay
so choice a is six six is not less than
five
choice b is four four is even four is
positive four is less than five so the
answer is b
and the other choices don't work because
c
one is
odd
d zero
zero is not positive and the last choice
e negative two well that's not that's
not positive either
problem number two
so our answer was b is equal to four
b the choice b was four problem number
two if eight
eight plus the square root of k
is equal to fifteen then what does k
equal
well subtract eight from both sides you
get square root of k is equal to
7
square both sides k is equal to 49.
next problem
problem number three
see if i can
clear image
problem number three
in a poll 35 people were in favor of
building a new library
so 35
yes
they want it
14
against it 14 said no
and one person
doesn't know one person has no opinion
what fraction of those polled were in
favor of a building
were in favor of building a new library
so the people were in favor were 35
and the fraction of the total people
polled so the total people polled was 35
plus
14
plus 1 right
and what is this that's 50. so that's
equal to 35
over
50.
and 35 over 50 if we divide the top and
the bottom by 7 you get 7 10.
so the answer is a
seven tenths were in favor of the
library problem number four
we've got a kind of crazy looking figure
here see we have a line that goes
something like this
and we have let's see it goes like that
and then it goes like
this
it looks something like that
close enough
and what's going on here so they tell us
that this one this angle is 70
that's 70. this is 30.
and they say that this is t
and this is u you probably can't read
that but you see it in your own book and
the figure above what is the value of t
plus u
this is the angle game again let's see
what angles we can figure out so
this is 70 this is 30.
so this angle right here plus 70 plus 30
has to equal 180 right
this angle plus 70 plus 30 70 plus 30 is
100
so this is 80 degrees right here
if this is 80 degrees this is the
opposite angle to 80 degrees so that's
going to also be 80 degrees learn that
in geometry class
and so if this is 80 degrees what is
what first of all what are all of these
angles combined equal t plus u plus 80
are all in the same triangle so they
have to add up to 180 and so we know
that t plus u is going to has to be 100
degrees
and that's choice c
next problem
invert okay problem number five
oh there's a big graph according to the
graph above between which two
consecutive years was the greatest
change
in the price of coffee oh i think i'm
going to have to draw this just so that
you
see what i see hopefully
okay
and then let me just write the years so
this is it goes to 81 through 86 so 81
let's see in 1981
so let's see we have
three dollars
375
3.75 we have four
425
425
four fifty
four
seventy five
in 1981
it cost three dollars and seventy five
cents it's gonna take me a little time
to draw this whole thing in 1982 it was
at 350.
oops that's 359 here not three
let me write that that's 350.
back to what i was doing in 1983 it went
to 425
83 it's like 425
1984 went all the way to 475 1984
475
1985 was it 375 again
g5 look something like that
and then 1986 goes to 450
1986 450.
okay and what are they asking us
according to the graph above between
which two consecutive years was the
greatest change in the price of coffee
well let's figure that out
so here the change is
25 at 25 cents here the change going
from this year to this year
it's let's see 25 50 75 cents that's a
good contender right there
75 cents going from here to here we only
had a 50 cent change
50 50 change then we went from 475 to
350. so this is a pretty big change
actually this looks like our winner
that's from 475
to actually 375 so this is one dollar
change and then we went from 375 to 450
so we had a 75 change again
so the biggest change happened from 1984
to 1985. choice d
all that work for a fairly
straightforward problem
next problem
problem number six more drawing for me
okay
let's see more drawing
got to be focus sal focused
okay this is negative one this is
negative two
this is one this is two
one and two and what does this graph
look like
let's see we go like from
we go like from
here to here
looks like
then we stay
we go flat here
and then we go
like this
and then we go flat again
and what are they asking the graph
of y equals g of x so this is y is equal
to g of x
as shown above
if g of k
is equal to 1
which of the following is a possible
value of k so g of k is equal to 1. so
when does this graph equal 1
well this graph equals one
and then different color it equals one
heat oh it equals one here it equals one
this entire period right this is all of
these values are where g
of x is equal to 1.
so what could be the values of k well
the values of k can be anywhere between
negative 1
and 0. all of those could be values ok
anywhere
from here because at all of these values
g of k is equal to 1. so let's see they
have choices minus 1.5 is here that's no
that's over there minus 0.5 minus 0.5 is
right here
and g of minus 0.5 is right here so
that's 1. g of minus 0.5 is equal to 1.
so that looks pretty good
so that is our answer problem uh choice
b
see if i can squeeze in
problem number seven i think that would
be the most videos i've ever done in a
in 10 most problems in 10 minutes
if a b and c are different positive
integers
and
2 to the a
times 2 to the b
times 2 to the c is equal to 64.
then they want to know what is 2 to the
a
plus
2 to the b
plus
2 to the c
fascinating
well what do we know about exponent
rules 2 to the a times 2 to the b times
2 to the c that's
2 to the
a plus b plus c
right
and we also what's 2 to the what power
is 64.
two to the sixth power right
two to the sixth power is 64. right
actually i'm going to run out of time so
i'm going to do this in the next video i
only have 15 seconds left
see you soon